to steal from the empire  you just walk in like you belong  they're so proud of themselves  so fat and satisfied  they can't imagine  that someone like me  would ever get inside their house  cassian ander  the empire is choking us so slowly  we're starting not to notice  what i'm asking is this  wouldn't you rather give it all  to something real  [Music]  i need all the heroes i can get  for the greater good  call it what you will let's call it  war  there's fermenting out there some  pockets of fermenting  [Music]  you're in my net  are you a fish  or are you a thief  you're slipping  i'm not sleeping  i've just been hiding for too long  as long as everyone thinks i'm an  irritation  there's a good chance they'll miss what  i'm really doing what are you really  doing  [Music]  this is what revolution looks like  [Music]  i'm tired of losing  [Music]  [Music]  you